على كل حال سالنا الناس من الاقوى تاثيرا
في العمل الموظف الصامت ام الموظف المتحدث
[موسيقى]
انا فايل موظف المتكلم يبقى افضل المتكلم
ده هو اللي بيعرف ينقض المكان
الصامت ده ما بيشوفش السلبيات معظم
مشاكلنا من شخص الصامت الشخصيه ممكن ينصح
اللي قدامه ممكن يقول له حاجات صح يوتيوب
في شغله وفي عمله وفي نفس الوقت لكن
الصامت انا هستفيد منه ايه متكلم ده على
حسب برضو بيتكلم في ايه فاهم ممكن تكون دي
شخصيته مع ذلك برضو هيطلع شغله كويس
وهيشتغل كويس بس هو شخصيته ان هو متكلم
صامت في الحياه لا ما بينفعش المتكلم في
الحقيقه دلوقتي هو اللي بينفع كل واحد
هيبقى له تاثير بطريقه معينه تاثير في حته
والمتكلم
وهي دي الشطاره بقى حتى قالوا في زمان
يعني اللي هو الكلام من فضه فصمت من ذهب
يعني
[موسيقى]